This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I am walking down 106 Street towards Manhattan Avenue. I can see the building in distance. That's producer Jessica Miller, wandering around her old neighborhood. Oh yeah! So you can see on the back of this tower there's like a smoke stack, or at least the remnant of a smoke stack Jess used to live near Central Park and she's been walking by this building and wondering about it for a long time So she met up with Jim Rassenberger who's done some writing about the building for the New York Times. Hey, are you Jim? Yes, how are you nice to meet you?
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我正沿着106街朝曼哈顿大道走去。我能看到远处的那座建筑。那是制作人杰西卡·米勒（Jessica Miller），她正在她以前的街区闲逛。哦，对！所以你可以看到这座塔的背面有一个烟囱，或者至少是烟囱的遗迹。杰西卡以前住在中央公园附近，她经常路过这栋建筑，并对它好奇了很久。于是她找到了吉姆·拉森伯格（Jim Rassenberger），他曾为《纽约时报》撰写过一些关于这座建筑的文章。嘿，你是吉姆吗？是的，你好，很高兴见到你！
The address of the building is 455 Central Park West, and it looks like a castle. It's huge. It takes up the whole east end of the block. It's made up of red brick with this intricate stone trim, and it's got five or so large cylindrical turrets with silver cones on top. It's gigantic. Gigantic.
这座建筑的地址是中央公园西路455号（455 Central Park West），它看起来像一座城堡。它非常巨大。它占据了整个街区的东端。它由红砖建成，带有精致的石质饰边，大约有五座大型圆柱形炮塔，顶部带有银色圆锥体。它大得惊人。大得惊人。
I was gonna say ginormous. You could say ginormous. The building looks like something out of a fairy tale. Like Rapunzel could let down her hair through one of the turret windows for some night and shining armor who just wandered over from Central Park. But what I found out is that this building's past is not very fairy tale like at all. And you want to like just take a walk around the building and see what we see? I thought coming up around this side there are these things that look like smoke stacks kind of off of this back top. I mean the main the main smoke stack
我本来想说“庞大得离谱”。你可以说庞大得离谱。这栋建筑看起来就像童话里出来的东西。就像长发公主可以从其中一个炮塔的窗户放下她的长发，迎接某个刚刚从中央公园闲逛过来的身披闪亮铠甲的骑士。但我发现，这座建筑的过去一点也不像童话。你想绕着这座建筑走一圈，看看我们能看到什么吗？我以为走到这边会有一些看起来像烟囱的东西，差不多在这个后背顶部。我的意思是，主烟囱
has been torn down and it was part of the crematorium where they used to burn bodies. Well that's just a good dark turn. So, the building has been renovated, but when it was built in 1887, it was the country's first hospital devoted solely to the treatment of cancer. And they weren't very good at treating cancer yet, so that Crematorium Smokestack,
已经被拆除了，它曾是火葬场的一部分，他们过去常在那里焚烧尸体。好吧，这真是一个黑暗的转折。所以，这座建筑经过了翻新，但当它于1887年建成时，它是全国第一家专门治疗癌症的医院。而且他们当时还不擅长治疗癌症，所以那个火葬场的烟囱，
it was smoking pretty often. The old castle-like building at 455 Central Park West can actually tell us a lot about the history of cancer and the history of hospital architecture. But let's set the scene a little bit. It's the late 1800s, and people seem to know that cancer starts as a tumor, and that sometimes the tumor can be removed, but they don't know a whole lot beyond that. And a lot of hospitals in the US don't even want to treat cancer patients.
经常冒烟。位于中央公园西路455号的这座古老的城堡式建筑实际上可以告诉我们很多关于癌症历史和医院建筑历史的信息。但让我们先交代一下背景。那是19世纪末，人们似乎知道癌症是由肿瘤引起的，有时肿瘤可以被切除，但除此之外他们知之甚少。美国的好多医院甚至都不愿意治疗癌症患者。
Some people feared the disease. They thought it was contagious. Some doctors thought it was contagious. And also, there was a lot of stigma about having the disease. That's Elaine Schatner. She's a clinical associate professor of medicine at Wal-Cornell Medical College.
有些人对这种疾病感到恐惧。他们认为这是传染性的。有些医生也认为它是传染性的。此外，患这种病还有很大的社会污名。那是伊莱恩·沙特纳（Elaine Schatner）。她是威尔康奈尔医学院（Weill Cornell Medical College）的临床内科副教授。
And she's writing a book about cancer awareness. On top of misconceptions about cancer being contagious, there was another reason that hospitals might have hesitated to take cancer patients. At the time, they had to publish their death rates, so they'd turn away patients who were likely to skew the numbers. This is why you had tuberculosis hospitals and other specialty hospitals for diseases that were particularly deadly. In the late 1800s, Europe was a bit ahead of the U.S. in terms of cancer treatment. During and after the Civil War, patients in the United States who had money or could
她正在写一本关于癌症意识的书。除了认为癌症会传染的误解之外，医院可能对接收癌症患者有所顾虑还有另一个原因。当时，他们必须公布死亡率，因此他们会拒绝那些可能会拉低数据的患者。这就是为什么当时会有肺结核医院和其他专门针对致死率极高疾病的专科医院。在19世纪末，欧洲在癌症治疗方面比美国略胜一筹。在南北战争期间及之后，美国有钱或负担得起去欧洲的患者会去那里接受治疗。而当时大部分教育程度有限的美国医生则会去欧洲学习科学、病理学和外科技术。其中一个人就是J·马里恩·西姆斯（Jay Marion Sims）。西姆斯去欧洲学习了一些切除癌症的外科技术。他想把这些知识带回美国，他以前曾在纽约妇女医院工作过，然后在1874年，这家医院做出了决定。
afford to go to Europe would do so for care. And doctors from the United States who then, you know, for the most part, had minimal education would go to Europe to study science and pathology and surgical techniques. One such man was Jay Marion Sims. Sims went to Europe and learned a few surgical techniques for removing cancer. He wanted to bring this knowledge back to the US where he had worked previously at the New York Women's Hospital and then in 1874, the hospital decided.
他们不允许患有癌症的女性入住。出于我们刚刚讨论的所有原因，他们认为这太致命了，可能具有传染性。因此，在1884年，一些慈善家，包括伊丽莎白·科勒姆（Elizabeth Column）——她的儿子死于癌症，后来她自己也死于这种疾病——为后来成为第一家专门致力于癌症护理的医院奠基。它于1887年开业，由查尔斯·黑特（Charles C. Haight）的建筑师设计。早些时候我说过这家医院看起来像童话里的城堡，事实证明
They wouldn't let women with cancer in. For all the reasons we just talked about, it was too deadly, they thought it might be contagious. So in 1884, some philanthropists, including Elizabeth Column, who had lost her son to cancer and later died from the disease herself, broke ground on what would become the first hospital exclusively devoted to cancer care. It opened in 1887 and was designed by Architects of Charles Hate. Earlier I talked about the hospital looking like a castle from a fairy tale, and it turns
这在当时的医院中是一种很常见的风格。它们看起来像城堡，看起来像贵族的宅邸，我们在其建筑中可以看到它们有围墙、有门房、有精致的入口，有时还有炮塔，它们拥有非常非常富裕的街区的所有特征。从建筑外观来看，它们非常具有住宅感。那是安妮·玛丽·亚当斯（Ann Marie Adams）。嗨，我是安妮·玛丽·亚当斯。我是麦吉尔大学（McGill University）建筑学院院长。
out that was a pretty common style for hospitals at that time. They looked like like castles, they look like aristocratic mansions and we see in the architecture that they have they they're walled, they have gate houses, they have elaborate entries, sometimes turrets, they have all the trappings of a very very wealthy neighborhood. They're very domestic in their architectural outlook. That's Ann Marie Adams. Hi, I'm Ann Marie Adams. I'm Director of the School of Architecture at McGill University.
她还写过关于这一时期医院的文章，她说在19世纪末，医院是由富裕慈善家经营的慈善机构，穷人们去那里寻求治疗。有钱人主要仍然在家里接受治疗，但医院管理者想要改变这一点。建筑是一种说服的工具，用来吸引较富裕的人来到医院接受治疗。
She's also written about hospitals from this time period, and she says that in the late 1800s, hospitals were charitable institutions run by wealthy philanthropists where poor people went for care. Rich people still mostly received care at home, but hospital administrators wanted to change that. Architecture is a tool of persuasion to convince wealthier people to come to the hospital to be healed.
因此，在1887年，第一家癌症医院向付费和不付费的癌症患者敞开大门，并努力成为一个对付费客户具有吸引力的地方。甚至连食物也很好。所以他们有很棒的厨师，你知道，保持竞争力的一部分就是拥有真正美味的食物。人们去医院的餐厅
So in 1887, the first cancer hospital opened its doors to both pain and non-paying patients with cancer, and it tried hard to be an inviting place for paying customers. Even the food was good. So they had great chefs, you know, part of being competitive was having really good food. People went to hospital dining rooms
庆祝生日等特殊场合。就像我们今天可能会去酒店的餐厅一样，即使我们并没有住在该酒店。我所以这显然发生了很大的变化。酒店的对比非常贴切。癌症医院的设计主要是为了姑息治疗，换句话说，就是让人们感到舒适并缓解疼痛。所以他们举办香槟派对。
to celebrate special occasions like birthdays. Like we might today go to a hotel dining room, even though if we're not staying at the hotel. I'm so that obviously's changed a lot. The hotel comparison is pretty spot on. The Kinser Hospital was designed mostly for palliative care, in other words just making people comfortable and relieving pain. So they had champagne parties.
他们带人们去中央公园坐马车兜风。再次强调，那是吉姆·拉森伯格，我在故事开头遇到的人。这是一座美丽的建筑，旨在变得美丽，这样人们就不会觉得自己要去一个可怕的地方等死，而是觉得要去法国乡村。那些有许多窗户、让建筑看起来像城堡的大圆炮塔
They took people on carriage rides in central park. Again, that's Jim Rassenberger, who I met up with at the beginning of the story. It was a beautiful building and meant to be beautiful, so that people didn't feel like they were going off to a terrible place to die, but rather going off to the French countryside. And the big round turrets with lots of windows that make the building look like a castle
实际上是容纳病人的病房。嗯，病人在周边的床位上，大概有10或11张床。然后医生会进来，一张床接一张床地查房。为了确保你能真切地想象出这一点，这些房间是完全圆形的，直径约40英尺。
were actually wards that house patients. Well, the patients were in beds around the perimeter, and there would be 10 or 11 beds. And so the doctor would come in and make his rounds from bed to bed to bed. Just to make sure you can really picture this, the rooms were perfectly circular in about 40 feet in diameter.
从其中一个房间的鸟瞰图来看，有点像钟表的表盘，床位环绕在四周。但圆形房间不仅仅是为了美观。通过拥有这些圆形的房间、减少死角，人们认为可以保持医院清洁。你知道，污垢会在角落里积聚，所以只要去掉角落就行了。这简直太绝了。这家医院以及当时其他医院的另一个显著特点是拥有大量的窗户。
And an aerial view of one of the rooms looked a bit like the face of a clock with beds around the perimeter. But the round rooms weren't just about aesthetics. By having these rounded rooms fewer corners, I thought that you could keep the hospital cleaner. You know, dirt accumulates in corners, so just get rid of the corners. It's kind of brilliant. Another distinguishing feature of this hospital and of others at the time was tons of windows.
其理念是，打开的窗户可以让新鲜空气冲刷患者之间的空间。当然，这迎合了疾病通过糟糕的空气传播的观点。这种认为疾病是由受污染的恶臭空气传播的观点被称为瘴气理论。但奇怪的是，当癌症医院建成时，瘴气理论已经被细菌理论彻底驳倒了，细菌理论正确地认为疾病是通过细菌或微生物传播的。
And the idea was that the open window would allow fresh air to flush the space between the patients. And this, of course, played into the idea that sicknesses traveled in bad air. This idea that sickness was spread by polluted smelly air was called the measma theory. But the weird thing is, by the time the cancer hospital was built, the measma theory had been debunked by the germ theory, which rightly held that diseases spread through germs or microbes.
建筑学当时还没有跟上。医院的建筑设计并不总是与当时的医学理论完全一致。几乎就像社会在犹豫是否要完全赞同这一医学理论。明亮通风的房间、香槟派对、穿过公园的马车兜风，这一切听起来都挺迷人的。直到我们听到关于在医学意义上没有人知道自己在做什么的部分。除了姑息治疗，当时治疗癌症的主要手段是手术，
The architecture just hadn't caught up yet. The architectural design of a hospital doesn't always correspond exactly to the medical theories of that time. Almost like society is hesitating to fully endorse the medical theory. Light, airy rooms, champagne parties, carriage rides through the park, it all sounds kind of charming. Until we get to the part about how nobody had any idea what they were doing, medically speaking. Beyond palliative care, the main treatment for cancer at the time was surgery,
但癌症手术仍然极其原始。你知道，这只是一种对带有肿瘤的人进行的大规模切割，其目的是切除他们体内的每一个淋巴结，并在能让他们活下来的前提下尽可能多地切除。手术风险也极高。这是在抗生素出现之前的时代，因此很多人在手术后因感染而死，但绝望的病人会采取绝望的措施。你知道，如果医生说我能把这个从你身上取下来，而且它正在引起疼痛和流血，你知道，人们通常会同意。我能把你身上的这个切除，它之前一直在引起疼痛和出血。
but surgery for cancer was still incredibly primitive. You know, just sort of massive cutting of people with tumors, with the idea of removing every lymph node in their body and as much as possible, it could be done while keeping them alive. Surgery was also hugely risky. This was before the time of antibiotics, so a lot of people died from infections after surgery, but desperate patients take desperate measures. You know, if a doctor said I can take this out of you and it was causing pain and bleeding, you know, people would often agree. I can take this out of you and it was causing pain and bleeding.
你知道，人们通常会同意。纽约癌症医院的手术和其他当时的医院一样，是在圆形阶梯教室里进行的，以便学生们观看和学习。我看的Cinemax上有一个名为《纽约杏林》（The Knick）的节目，它生动地戏剧化了同一时期的这些阶梯教室手术。我希望学生们注意，克里斯蒂安·辛（Christian Zin）医生正在耻骨正上方的中线上切入。正如你所看到的，体腔内有大量的血液，谢谢，记住。那个时期的外科医生在做开创性的工作。而患者则是开创性的试验品。
You know, people would often agree. The surgeries at the Cancer Hospital in New York, as in other hospitals at that time, were happening in an amphitheater, so that students could watch and learn. There's a show on cinematics that I watch called the Nick, but graphically dramatizes these amphitheater surgeries from around the same time period. I want the students to take note that Dr. Christian Sun is entering on the media line just above the pubes. As you can see, there is significant blood in the cavity, thank you, remember. Surgeons from this time were doing pioneering work. In patients, we're pioneering guinea pigs.
总得从某个地方开始。但那个节目让我感到无比庆幸，庆幸自己生活在20世纪。完全同意，情况确实很糟糕，而且癌症患者的这种情况持续了相当长的一段时间。直到1920年，也只有大约15%的患者在确诊癌症后存活了两年以上。几乎所有人都死了，所以数据非常惨淡，而在1900年，数据甚至更糟糕。这一定就是为什么他们觉得有必要在现场建一个火葬场。如果你当时在那里，这一定是一个非常诡异的场景
And I had to start somewhere. But that show makes me so so happy that I live in the 20th century. Agreed, things were bad and they stayed bad for cancer patients for quite a while. As late as 1920, only 15% or so of patients survived cancer diagnosis for more than two years. Almost everyone died, so the numbers were bleak, and in 1900 the numbers were even worse. Which must be why they felt they needed a crematorium on site. Which must have been a really spooky site if you were there
你可以看着窗外看到烟囱。想象一下往外看，看到烟囱里冒出烟来。那一定相当糟糕。在滚滚浓烟之下，纽约癌症医院很快获得了一个绰号——巴士底狱（The Bastille）。它试图看起来像一个法国城堡（château），但最终给人的感觉却像是一个法国监狱。这就是为什么尽管对癌症治疗的需求巨大，这家医院却无法吸引人们走进大门。事实是，极少有人愿意去纽约癌症医院，
and you could look at your window and see the smoke stack. And imagine looking out there and seeing smoke come out of that smoke stack. That would have been pretty awful. Under that billowing smoke, the New York Cancer Hospital soon earned a nickname, the Bastille. It was trying to look like a French at toe, but it ended up feeling like a French prison. Which is why, despite a huge demand for cancer treatment, the hospital couldn't get people in the door. The fact is that very few people wanted to go to the New York Cancer Hospital,
令人惊奇的是，这家医院在财务上举步维艰。1900年之前以及之后的很长一段时间里，癌症护理并不是一项赚钱的生意。这家医院还试图通过引入一种有争议的新型药物来吸引患者和资金：镭。有一段时间，大约在1920年，纽约癌症医院夸耀自己拥有全国最大的单一镭藏库。玛丽·居里（Marie Curie）于1921年参观了镭藏库，此行登上了各大媒体头条。但放射疗法，甚至比手术更甚，当时并未被人们所理解。
and what's amazing is that the place struggled financially, cancer care, before 1900, and for a long time after it was not lucrative. The hospital also tried to attract patients and funds by procuring a controversial new form of medicine. Radium. For a while, around 1920, the New York Cancer Hospital boasted the country's single largest repository of radium. Marie Curie visited to check out the radium repository in 1921, in a trip that made headlines. But radiation therapy, even more so than surgery, was not understood.
它是由那些不懂得如何施用的人管理的，因为他们并没有真正理解它。许多放射科工作人员、医生和护士自己也得了癌症。直到20世纪30年代左右，情况才开始有所改善。手术变得更好，放射治疗也开始发挥作用。我认为在20世纪60年代和70年代，随着化学疗法的出现以及对癌症护理更加系统化的方法的采用，最终使其成为一项非常赚钱的业务。1939年，癌症医院离开了
It was administered by people who didn't know how to administer it because they didn't really understand it. And a lot of the radiation workers, doctors and nurses themselves developed cancer. It wasn't until the 1930s or so that things started to improve. Surgery became better, the radiation treatments were working. I think in the 1960s and 1970s then you have chemotherapy and just much more, a much more organized approach to cancer care, and one that ultimately became very lucrative. In 1939, the Cancer Hospital left
位于中央公园西路455号的旧址，搬到了上东区（Upper East Side），并在那里成为了纪念斯隆-凯特琳癌症中心（Memorial Sloan-Kettering），如今它被公认为美国最好的癌症治疗医院之一。当然，医院看起来不再像城堡了。第一次世界大战后，医院开始看起来像小型公民机构，更像是市政厅或学校。它们非常方正，被称为“街区平面图”（block plan）。我们还看到了带有许多床位的大型开放式病房的消失。付费患者可以期望住单人房，普通患者则可以住双人房或四人房。
for 55 Central Park West for the Upper East Side, where it became Memorial Sloan Catering, which is now known as one of the best hospitals for cancer treatment in the US. And of course, hospitals don't look like castles anymore. After World War One, hospitals start to look like small civic institutions more like city halls or or schools. They're very square that it's called the block plan. We also see the end of big open woods with lots of beds. Paying patients could expect single rooms or typical patients could be in a double room or a room of four patients.
我们告别了美食、香槟和马车兜风。资金被投入到手术室和机械设备等事物中，而不是装饰上。我们看到木制床和梳妆台消失了，一切都变成了金属制品，并带有一种高效的外观。第二次世界大战后，办公楼兼摩天大楼成为了医院的模版。这一切在20世纪80年代随着我们所称的“以患者为中心的护理”的兴起而再次发生改变，中庭式医院（atrium hospital）迅速流行起来。
And we said goodbye to good food, champagne, and carat rites. The money was channeled in things like surgical suites and in mechanical equipment rather than in decoration. And we see things like wooden beds and dressers disappear, everything becomes metal and has a kind of look of efficiency. After World War II, the office building slash skyscraper becomes the model for hospitals. It all changes again in the 1980s with the onset of what we call patient-centered care, where the atrium hospital just takes off.
这些是看起来像购物中心的医院，只有一两层楼，有着巨大的开放空间。我的意思是，这是20世纪医院发展史的一个微型缩影。我们现在已经完全抛弃了圆形房间，但圆形房间更容易保持清洁这一总体理念实际上一直保留了下来。因此，在墙壁与地面的交界处，如果你今天去参观医院，你会发现它可能是呈弧形的，这样就不会有任何东西卡在墙壁和地面之间的直角里。至于那座城堡式的建筑。墙壁和地面的交界处。至于那座容纳了第一家癌症医院的城堡式建筑，它们经历了一段
These are hospitals that look like shopping malls, just one or two floors, big open spaces. I mean, that's a very kind of capsule history of the 20th century hospital. We've done away with completely round rooms now, but the general idea of round rooms being easier to keep clean has actually persisted. So where the wall meets the floor, if you go visit the hospital today you'll see it's probably curved so that nothing could get stuck in the right angle between the wall and the floor. As for the castle-like building wall and the floor. As for the castle-like building that housed the first cancer hospital, they went through
另一个真正黑暗的时期。在20世纪50年代中期，它变成了塔楼疗养院（Tower Nursing Home）。它成了纽约最臭名昭著的疗养院之一。那是一个发生可怕事情的地方，蟑螂在墙壁周围爬行，患者受到虐待。该疗养院于20世纪70年代被关闭，大楼长期空置并处于失修状态。
another really dark period. In the mid-1950s, it becomes tower nursing home. That becomes one of the most notorious nursing homes in New York. And is a place where terrible things happen, roaches crawling around walls, and patients being abused. The nursing home was shut down in the 1970s, and the building sat vacant and in a state of disrepair for a long time.
吉姆·罗森伯格在80年代经常从它旁边走过，并说这是一个诡异的地方。它就像鬼屋一样，你知道，但它甚至比那更好。它是一座鬼城堡。它似乎在不断地走向坍塌成一堆砖块的命运。真的，似乎没有办法摆脱这种命运，因为它变得如此糟糕，以至于你会想，好吧，现在谁会搬进这里来呢？
Jim Rassenberger used to walk by it in the 80s and said it was a spooky place. It was like a haunted house, you know, but it was even better than that. It was a haunted castle. It just seemed to be on an everable fall into a pile of bricks. It was really, there didn't seem to be any escape from that fate because it got so bad you thought, well, who's going to come in here now?
我的意思是，谁会进来并试图让这座建筑重焕生机呢？那是20世纪80年代的纽约。在21世纪的曼哈顿，即使是鬼城堡也可以变成豪华公寓。2000年，这座建筑被一家开发商买下。现在它拥有17个公寓单元、一个停车场、一个水疗中心、一个游泳池和一个健身中心。公园里的医院城堡终于在内部变成了它在外部一直伪装成的样子：一个有钱人的好去处。99% Invisible本周由杰西卡·米勒和凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）以及萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）共同制作
I mean, who would come in and try to make something of this building? That was New York in the 1980s. In 21st century Manhattan, even haunted castles can be turned into luxury condominiums. In the year 2000 the building was bought by a developer. Now it's 17 condo units, a parking garage, a spa, a pool, and a fitness center. The hospital castle on the park finally became on the inside, would it always pretended to be on the outside. A nice place for rich people. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Jessica Miller and Katie Mingle with Sam Greenspan
还有艾弗里·特罗布曼（Avery Trufelman）和我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，由Ars Nova的办公室制作，这是一个心胸宽广、富有协作精神的建筑事务所，慷慨地在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心为我们提供了家。你可以在Twitter、Facebook、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上关注99PI的所有最新动态。如果你打个招呼，我向你保证，只要你写个“嗨”，我就会在Twitter上回你一个“嗨”。我向你保证。
Avery Troubleman and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxan, an open-hearted, collaboratively-minded architecture firm that generously gives us our home in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can keep up with all the coming and goings of 99PI on Twitter, Facebook, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify. If you say hi, I guarantee if you just write hi, I will write hi back to you on Twitter. I guarantee it.
并且随时欢迎你来到我们的网站 99pi.org。本节目由 PRX 提供 P.I. 广播。此单集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
And you're always welcome in our place at 99pi.org. Radio to P.I. From P.R.X. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并且我们随时欢迎您访问 99pi.org。来自 P.R.X. 的 Radio to P.I.。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。